[موسيقى]
وصلتنا هاي البنت مبارح الساعه ثلاثه بعد
الظهر مع كدمات عديده ومع ساحجات كامل
جسمها البنت جتنا كمان بازيه برد البنت
شديد تمتد فئه الطفل
اعطاء سكر
ووضع الانستقر
[موسيقى]
بالالاف قضاء سنينكاره لا فرق عند الاموات
اسباب موتهم فهم ذهبوا وتركوا وراءهم الاف
القطرات من الدموع لا كلمات تصف الفاجعه
ولا عبارات تخفف الام المكلومين اعداد
الضحايا بازدياد وصرخات تحت الانقاض قد
يحالف الحظ بعدها فيصل صداه الى فرقه
انقاذ تتمكن من انتشاله ان توفرت لديها
الامكانيات وخلف الحدود صرخات اخرى
لاقرباء مفجوعين تركوا عائلاتهم جنوب
تركيا املا بحياه او بلقاء يجمعهم يوما
هنيئا لمن نجاه وتعزينا لاهالي الضحايا
وعائلتهم
يعني يعني شيء رعب يعني
[موسيقى]
ستنا ثانيه ليس اكثر وقوعها مدمر
وارتداداتها اكثر تدميرا ولا تزال متواصله
تلك هي مده زلزال الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا
وغير حياه اكثر من 23 مليون شخص
زلزال بقوه 7.9 درجه ضرب في السادس من
فبراير على عمق نحو 17 كيلو مترا قرب
مدينه غازي عنتاب جنوبي تركيا اي على عمق
عشره كيلومترات فقط قرب مدينه كهرمان مرعش
وكانت الساعه حينها الواحده وسبعه عشره
دقيقه بتوقيت جرينتش ووفق شهود الزلزال
استمر دقيقه واحده وصفت بدقيقه الموت
مدمرا المباني في المناطق المذكوره ونوافذ
منازل في مدن تبعد نحو 300 كيلومترا شرقا
مثل ديار بكر
الزلزال في سوريا لم يكن اخف بل اركع
مباني متهالكه تحاول جاهده التماسك بعد
حرب استمرت اثني عشر عاما لتتجدد صور
الحطام وانتشال الجثث والمصابين والذين
قدروا بالالاف
بعد 11 دقيقه من الزلزال الاول تعرضت
المنطقه لهزه ارتداديه بلغت قوتها 6.7
درجه لتبدا الكارثه حيث لم تنتهي سابقتها
زلزال اخر اعقبها بقوه 7.5 درجه تالته هزه
اخرى بقوه 6 درجات في فتره ما بعد الظهر
مع توقعات بامتداد النشاط الزلزلي الى
فجوه مجاوره
الدولتين لملممه ما تيسر والانصات لهمهمه
عالقين تحت الانقاض تغص المشافي بالمصابين
الذين ملئوا الممرات دون قدره على علاجهم
فيما اخرون نفذوا من براثن الزلزال لتتكسر
على اجسادهم عاصفه ليست اقل رحمه
[موسيقى]
من الحدود السوريه التركيه معنى الصحفيه
مصطفى النعيمي يبدو زيدان زنجلو لدمانه
زيدان اهلا بك معنا هل يمكن ان تطلعنا مال
جديد الان وماذا لدينا من تفاصيل حول
الحصيله حتى الان
نعم ميسون نحن نتواجد في مدينه اضنه قرب
احد او امام احد المواقع المدمره نتيجه
الزلزال ادى الكاميرا تقترب اكثر وانا
اواصل الحديث معكم هذا الموقع الذي نتواجد
فيه الان ميسون عباره عن بناء من اربعه
عشر طابقا بحسب ما اخبرنا به
اخبرني احد عمال الانقاذ حتى الان فرق
الانقاذ تحاول الوصول الى ناجين هم
متاكدين من وجود ناجين تحت هذا الركام
وتحت الانقاذ كان قبل حوالي ساعتين من
الان سمعوا اصوات من الداخل ومن ثم انقطعت
الاصوات سمعت تكررت الاصوات مرتين جاءتهم
من الداخل ما يؤكد وجود ناجين حتى الان
داخل هذا تحت هذا الركام توقفت الاصوات
لفتره ولم يعد لم تعد فرق الانقاذ تسمع اي
اصوات جديده لذلك استخدمت فريقا مختصا مع
كلاب مدربه واجهزه متقدمه وتم
ابعد بدايه كل العمال وكل فرق الانقاذ من
هذا المكان تقريبا استمرت الفريق استمر
بعمله مع الكلاب والاجهزه الحديثه لمده
نصف ساعه او من ثم اشار الى
بقيه فرق الانقاذ العوده وطلب منهم الحفر
في اماكن معينه يعتقد الفريق المختص ان
هناك ناجين في ذلك الموقع لذلك اعمال
الحفر ما تزال مستمره وازاله الركام
والكتل الخرسانيه الضخمه الموجوده في هذا
الموقع طبعا هذا الموقع هو احد المواقع
الموجوده في اضنه وفي ايضا في عشر ولايات
اخرى او في تسع ولايات اخرى اضافه الى
ولايه اضنهم ما تزال اعمال الانقاذ والبحث
عن ناجين مستمره حيث حيث حيث وصل عدد
الضحايا الى الالاف والجرحى عشرات الالاف
وفق ما اكلته وزاره الصحه التركيه ووزير
الصحه التركيه في مؤتمر صحفي
ادلب في مؤتمر صحفي قليل بالعموم
بالتوازي مع هذه الاعمال التي نشهدها الان
معكم على شاشه العربيه هناك
مساعدات تصل تباعا الى هذه المناطق
المنكوبه اكثر او اكثر المناطق منكوبه على
الترتيب هي ولايه هاتاي تريها ولايه
كهرمان مرعش التي كانت مصدر الزلزال او
التي كانت مركز الزلزال تليها ولايه
اديوان ثم ولايه غازي عنتاب هذه اربع
ولايات بالترتيب هي اكثر الولايات تضررا
من بين الولايات العشره طبعا
في هذه المنطقه المنكوبه في لحظه حصول هذا
الزلزال الى اين اتجهوا الى اي مناطق
يتجهون
نعم بدايه
تم اجلاء مثلا من نجا من هذا المبنى
والمباني المجاوره طبعا كلها فارغه من نجى
تم اجلاؤهم اولا تم التاكد من سلامتهم في
المشافي من قبل الفرق الطبيه ومن ثم تم
اجلائهم الى مراكز ايواء مؤقته من يريد
الخروج قبل قليل في او في ساعات قبل ساعات
من الان اعلنت شركات الطيران التركيه
وشركه طيران محليه ايضا فتح كل الرحلات
المتاحه طبعا من المطارات التي التي ما
زالت قيد الخدمه او ما زالت تعمل فتح
الرحلات بشكل مجاني للمواطنين الراغبين
بالخروج من هذه المناطق ربما هذا سيخفف
نوعا ما من الموجود على
الكوادر الطبيه او حتى كوادر الانقاذ او
حتى على
مراكز الايواء بالنسبه الى مراكز الايواء
حتى الان الحكومه التركيه يعني فتح جويا
لزياده اعداد او زياده عدد مراكز الايواء
ارسلت حتى ساعات المساء لا نتحدث حتى هذه
اللحظه او قبل الى ما قبل اربع ساعات كان
الحديث تقريبا عن 60 الف خيمه اضافه الى
اكثر من 100 الف بطانيه واغطيه وايضا البس
شتويه الى جميع المناطق المنكوبه طبعا حتى
الان حجم الدمار بشكل كامل غير لم يتضح
بشكل جلي او نسبه الدمار يعني حتى الان
السلطات تركيا تعتقد ان اعداد الفرق
الانقاذ ستتضاعف حتى ساعات الصباح
لذلك كان وزير الصحه يقول ان حجم الدمار
سيكون جليا اكثر يوم يوم الغد او في صباح
الغد ربما تتضح اكبر اكثر
والجرحى هل هي اوضاعهم جيده هل هناك مازال
حالات حرجه
نعم بشكل عام طبعا هناك الاوضاع الناجين
هناك اصابات متفرقه اصابات خفيفه يتم
التعاطي معها فورا في المشافي ومن ثم
اخراج هؤلاء الى مراكز ايواء والعنايه بهم
والحالات المتوسطه والحرجه يتم ابقائها في
المشفى لحين تلقي العلاج طبعا وحدات
العنايه المركزه تستقبل الحالات الحرجه
ايضا اكد وزير الصحه ان الكثير من الحالات
الحرجه تم نقلهم الى ما شاف طبعا عن طريق
الجو تم نقلهم الى مشافي في اسطنبول
وانقره لاستكمال العلاج بكل الاحوال ما
زالت الحكومه التركيه تامل من خلال زياده
عدد او من زياده من خلال زياده اطقم فرق
الانقاذ من الوصول الى ناجين اكثر او حتى
محاوله ازاله
الركام والانقاذ لمحاوله الوصول الى ناجين
اكثر وبالتالي قدر الامكان التخفيف من هذه
الموسيقى والاعداد الطرق كلها ام لانه في
بعض المناطق
تحول
الزلزال يعني وما خلفه من دمار للابنيه
كانت تعيق الطرقات حتى تصل فرق الانقاذ هل
حيثما انت هذا الامر موجود ام لا
في ولايه اضنه لا يوجد مثل هذه المشكله
كون اضنه فيها المطار مطار وهو المطار
الاساسي كما سماه نائب الرئيس التركي فؤاد
هذا اليوم قال ان هذا المطار بات مطار
اللوجستيان وعند وصولنا الى مطار اضنه
حقيقه
شاهدنا عشرات الطائرات التي وصلت سواء من
تركيا او من خارج تركيا وهي تحمل
المساعدات وشاهدنا مئات الاطقم سواء كان
طواقم طبيه او طواقم انقاذ قد وصلت وتستعد
للخروج من اضنه الى المناطق الاخرى في
اضنه لا توجد مثل هذه المشكله في مركز
ولايه اضنه لكن في بقيه الولايات نعم مثلا
في بعض الطرق بين غازي عنتاب وكهرمان مرعش
هناك مشكله في الطرق في انهيارات متعدده
سواء كان على الطريق السريع او حتى بعض
الطرق الفرعيه مثلا في الطرق بين ولايتي
غازي عنتاب وهاتاي هناك احد الطرق ايضا
المتضرره حتى مطار هاتاي في ضرر كما قال
احد المسؤولين الاتراك قبل قليل لذلك طبعا
هذه المشكله اضافه الى موضوع الانهيارات
الاحوال الجويه السيئه يعني اليوم الفرق
الطبيه التي في حال ارادت استخدام الطريق
البري هناك بعض النقاط التي يوجد فيها
صقيع وجليد وايضا ثلوج تعيق الوصول هذه
مشكله اضافيه
تعاني منها السلطات التركيه واطقم
الاطقم الطبيه او حتى اطقم فرق الانقاذ
اضافه الى ذلك طبعا المعدات الثقيله التي
يتم نقلها عبر هذه الطرق ايضا يعني وصول
هذه المعدات والاليات الى الاماكن التي
تريد الذهاب اليها يتطلب وقتا اضافيا في
حال لم تكن الطرق يعني سالكه اما
للانهيارات او للثلوج لذلك يتم استخدام
طرق بديله وفق ما اكد مسؤولون اتراك ولكن
هذا بشكل او باخر ربما يؤخر الى وصول هذه
الاليات وايضا كل المساعدات الى النقطه
المراد الوصول اليها بالوقت المناسب سنعود
اليك في نشاط لاحقا زيدان ايضا لتطلعنا
على اي تطور وخاصه بانه عمليات رفع
الانقاذ ما زالت مستمره في هذا المبنى حيث
تتواجد شكرا لك حتى الان من اضنا زيدان
العربيه على هذه الصوره الواضحه عما يحصل
الان في اضنه مشاهدينا سننتقل الان الى
هذه الصور المتداوله لطفل سوري يوثقوا
لحظه وجوده تحت الانقاض قبل انقاذه في
عفرين نتابع طبعا هذا الفيديو ما بعرف اذا
بدي اموت عايش
الحمد لله كل شيء
اشهد ان لا اله الا الله واشهد ان محمد
رسول الله
عايش ولكن زاد الفيديو نزل
انا الحمد لله طلعت عايش
الا واحده يعيشه عشت الشعور كنت تحت
الانقاذ
انتم شايفين حاليا
هاي تحت الانقاص والناس يعني
اكثر من من يمكن عيلتين ثلاثه اربع عيال
نحن وعيلتي
والجيران تبعتنا
الله يعين هسه ارضيه حرفيا
طبعا هذا الفيديو ما بعرف اذا اموت الله
شايفين
الحمد لله كل شيء
[موسيقى]
ما شاء الله ما شاء الله
الحمد لله على السلامه يا عمو
[موسيقى]
شوي شوي
الله اكبر ما شاء الله
من الحدود التركيه السوريه ينضم الينا
الان الصحفيه مصطفى نعيمه مصطفى اهلا بك
معنا تقريبا بعد اكثر من 35 ساعه على هذا
الزلزال كيف هي الاوضاع الان اين وصلت
اعمال
الانقاذ ورفع الانقاذ
تحياتي لك والاستاذ المشاهدين الكرام ربما
35 ساعه مرت لكن بالمقابل مره 54 هزه
ارضيه ارتداديه تتقارب الارقام بها عدد
الهزات للاسف الشديد يعني الهزات
الارتداديه كانت كبيره مرعبه وبنفس
التوقيت ادت الى هروب الناس من منازلهم
وتجمعهم في الطرقات وكذلك ايضا مصطفى اخر
هزه ارتداديه متى حصلت
قبل قراره حوالي الساعه والنصف في مركزها
في مدينه كهرمان مرعش والتي بلغت قرابه
4.2 درجه وشاهدت لحظه حدوث هذه الهزه وانا
موجود الان على الحدود السوريه التركيه
بالقرب من معبر باب الهوى على الطريق
الدولي طبعا حدثت الهزه وانا اشعر بها
بشكل دقيق جدا
يعني هل هزات الاعتداديه تكون قويه
تشعرون بها بشده نعم هذه الهزه كانت
بلغت 4.2 لكن ربما قد يكون هنالك هزات
ارتداديه اخرى نظرا لانه حتى هذه اللحظه
ما زالت الامطار تتساقط ما زال هنالك ايضا
يعني تحذيرات من السلطات تؤكد على انه في
حال تشققات في الابنيه عدم الدخول الى تلك
الابنيه وعدم الجلوس في تلك الابنيه لكن
يقابل ذلك في حال وجود يعني عندما نتحدث
عن
اجواء الشتاء ضرب قارس ايضا لا يوجد هنالك
ادوات للتدفئه الغالبيه العظمى منها من
المتواجدين في هذه المنطقه هم يعني
يستخدمون الغاز من اجل التدفئه او ربما
بعضهم الحطب الخاص الذي يشغل من خلال
التدفئه وكذلك ايضا التيار الكهربائي ايضا
منقطع لمسير احد وسائل التدفئه التي
استخدمها والتيار الكهربائي لا يوجد هنالك
تيار كهربائي منذ بدايه الزلزال حتى هذه
اللحظه يعني اوضاع الناس طبعا هي صعبه جدا
بوجود هذا الطقس القارس فضلا طبعا عن هذا
الزلزال ايضا نعم ايضا اردنا التحدث
على موضوع الهزات الارتداديه انت قلت بانه
هذه الهزات الابتداديه لن تتوقف واخر هزه
ارتداديه حصلت منذ ساعه ونصف صحيح نعم
تمام وكانت قويه يعني هل شعرتم بها بشكل
قوي نعم شعرنا بها وانا موجود الان يعني
في المكان ذاته شعرنا بها بشكل واضح جدا
بالنسبه لوضع الناس ايضا ماذا يمكن ان
تصفه لنا مصطفى
نعم شبكه المياه حاليا لا تعمل بسبب انه
لا يوجد تيار كهربائي كذلك ايضا شبكه تيار
الكهربائي لا توجد الانترنت والاتصالات
بشكل عام لا توجد الا في بعض النقاط
القريبه من الخدمات وهنا نتحدث الخدمات
اللوجستيه المقدمه للمدنيين كالمراكز
الامنيه وكذلك ايضا مستشفيات اضافه الى
المنطقه الحدوديه حيث معبر باب الهوى
والاداره المركزيه للمعبر لكن الطرق
الدوليه المؤديه من مدينه انطاكيا طريق
الدولي من مدينه انطاكيا باتجاه مدينه
اتجاه باب الهوى حتى هذه اللحظه يعمل بشكل
السيارات تتحرك فيه بشكل كبير جدا وحيث
انا متواجد لا توجد هنالك اي تعطيل للسير
وانما هنالك بعض اجزاء من الطريق فيها
حاله انهيارات تم تحويل السير الى الطرف
الاخر وما زالت هذه الطرق يعني مستمره
وانا اتحدث تحديدا ما بعد منطقه جسر
الحديد بالتحديد هنالك بعض الانهيارات
ولكن لم تكن هي معطله الانسيابيه او حركه
السير بشكل
بجانب معبر باب الهوى هل يمكن ان تصف لنا
يعني هناك الكثير من الانباء والاخبار
المتضاربه حول هذا المعبر بانه مغلق بانه
مفتوح بان مساعدات وصلت الى هذا المعبر هل
لدينا اي تفاصيل حول وضع باب الهواء معبر
باب الهوى
نعم لا يوجد هنالك اي مساعدات دخلت انا
اتحدث من الان يعني حتى الان لا يوجد
هنالك اي مساعدات قد وصلت ربما كما افاد
قبل قليل الاستاذ زيدان بان هنالك تحركت
الاطقم الطبيه وكذلك الاسعافيه لكن ربما
تحتاج قرابه من اربع الى خمس ساعات بسبب
ان هنالك تساقط للثلوج على الطريق المؤديه
الى مدينه هاتين
ولايه هاتاي المتضرره يعني هنالك اعلى
نسبه من الاضرار قد حصلت في هاتاي لذلك
تحتاج وقت طويل ربما قد نشاهد تلك الاطقم
بعد قليل لكن بالمقابل لا بد ان نذكر بان
هذه الاطقم التي جاءت هي لانقاذ هل هي
جاءت من اجل الشمال السوري ايضا هنالك
حالات حرجه جدا في الشمال السوري ربما
المستشفيات التركيه ليس بمقدورها استيعاب
حجم الكارثه التي تجري واينت عصر اليوم
المستشفى ودخلت الى داخل مدخل الطوارئ
لاحظت هنالك الالاف يتواجدون هنالك قرابه
100% من جثامين الضحايا الذين وصلوا من
المدن من مدينه الريحانيه كانوا من مدينتي
نار لجا وكذلك ايضا منطقه كرخان هنالك
الكثير من المباني قد سويت بالارض تماما
في هذا المستشفى هل هناك نقص في الكادر
الطبي في المواد الطبيه
لا يوجد هنالك نقص لكن عمليا نتحدث عن
مخزون هذه الاجهزه
قد ينفذ اذا ما
اذا حاله دخوله هؤلاء لكن هذا يتطلب ايضا
جهد جهد عن طريق المروحيات في حال تعثر
الوصول عبره الفرق البريه وفي حال الحاجه
الماسه يتطلب هذا ايضا جهود مضاعفه ليست
فقط تركيا وانما جهود امميه من اجل اداره
هذه الازمه واداره هذه الكارثه التي بلغت
طول امتداد الزلزال قرابه 850 كيلو متر
بعرض تقريبا بمعدل وسطي 400 كلم وانا
اتحدث عن حجم كبير هائل ليست مقدور مجموعه
من الدول اداره هذه الازمه اضافه للداخل
السوري يعني لا يوجد هنالك ادخال يعني في
حال هنا عبر شاشتكم اطالب المنظومه
الدوليه بان يتم ارسال هؤلاء المتطوعين
الذي الفرق الطبيه باتجاه معبر باب الهوى
وانشاء مشافي ميدانيه على المعبر من اجل
ايصاله هؤلاء الضحايا او هؤلاء العفوا
المصابين من اجل علاجهم داخل الاراضي
التركيه في حاله تعثر دخولها من الامراض
السوريه وهذا ما يخشى البعض من المنظمات
الدوليه دخولها الى سوريا لكن من من السهل
جدا ان يكون هنالك تفاهم ما بينه وبين
الحكومه التركيه على ان تن هذه المراكز
الصحفيه على الحدود السوريه التركيه
وبالاداره وتوافق مع الحكومه التركيه
وبالتالي هذا يساهم بشكل او باخر في عمليه
في تخفيض اعداد الجرحى وكذلك ايضا في
اعداد القتله الذين ليست مقدورهم من
الوصول الى مراكز طبيه المراكز الطبيه
والمراكز الطبيه حتى التي انشئت مؤخرا
كلها بات التعج بالجرحى كذلك ايضا الاطقم
الطبيه عفوا من الاسعافيه بحاجه ماسه الى
الادوات المعدات الثقيله من اجل انقاذ من
تبقى تحت الانقاض حتى في الجانبين التركي
والسوري وهذا يتطلب ايضا جهد مضاعف دولي
اتجاه تسيير او خلق نوع من الجسور الجويه
والبريه والبحريه فلواسكندرون لا يبعت
قرابه 100 كلم باتجاه معبر باب الهوى
بمقدور تلك الدول ان ترسل عبر البحار هذه
الاجهزه او المعدات الثقيله من اجل رفع
الانقراض المساهمه بشكل او باخر في تخفيف
عن المنظمه الخوذه البيضاء التي لم يناموا
افراده حتى هذه اللحظه اضافه كثير من
المتطوعين يعملون الى صفوف هذه المنظمه من
اجل تخفيف من اداء اداب المصابين وكذلك
انقاذ بعض الارواح وهذا ما قبل قليل
اعرضتموه في منطقه جنديرس هذا احد الاطفال
وهنالك الالاف من الاطفال هم تحت الانقاذ
والسبب الرئيسي في حجم الدمار هذا ان هذه
الابنيه لم تكن صالحه وانما انشات لاداره
ازمه بالاساس ليس بمقدورها
ان يعني ليس مقدور تلك الابنيه ان تتصدى
لتلك الهزات الارضيه ايضا طول فتره الحجاب
الارضيه ايضا تؤدي الى مشاكل كبيره في
الابنيه وقبل قليل هذه الهزه التي وصلت
كانت مدتها قرابه الدقيقتين بمعنى اخر ان
هذه قد بعضها من الممكن ان تنهار بشكل او
باخر
ان لا يحدث ذلك اشكرك الصحفيه مصطفى نعيمي
من الحدود التركيه السوريه على هذه
التفاصيل والمعلومات
الى ميناء اسكندرون الان حيث تظهر الصور
التي ترصدها كاميرا العربيه هناك استمرار
الحرائق في الميناء
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
حلقه جديده من المقاس المتواليه التي
تواجه السوريين شكلها زلزال امس ففي
مخيمات يرتجف ساكنها من برد قارس ويعيشون
في خيم لا ترد عنهم صقيع الشتاء تحاول فرق
الطوارئ في جميع انحاء المنطقه المنكوبه
الاستجابه بسرعه والحفره بادوات بسيطه تحت
المطر وفي ظل اجواء بارده لكن حجم الدمار
كان اكبر من امكانيات عمال الانقاذ الذين
اعتادوا على التعامل مع المباني المنهاره
جراء غارات النظام السوري بحسب الصحيفه
نيوربيه ففي مناطق شمال ريف حلب التي لا
تخضع لسيطره النظام اوضح الكثير من
الاهالي انهم يخشون البقاء في مباني قد
تنهار في اي لحظه وانهم يفضلون البقاء في
سيارات في اماكن مفتوحه اما المستشفيات
فكان الزمن عاد بها الى سنوات القتال
والقصف حيث اقتضت بالمرضى الذين يتشاركون
الاسره انتشر الاطباء في كل زاويه وركنان
لمعالجه الضحايا
يعمل
حكى الباب حكي
ما شاء
الله
الحمد لله على السلامه يا عمو
الحمد لله على السلامه
[موسيقى]
شوي شوي
الله اكبر ما شاء الله
[موسيقى]
تداعيات الزلزال المدمر لا تزال مستمره
وتلقي بظلالها على المشهد والصمخاوف من
سكان المدن الساحليه القريبه من وقوع
السينامي تاتي تلك المخاوف على خلفيه
تصريحات اطلقها عدد من المسؤولين الاتراك
من بينهم رئيس مرصد الزلازل في البلاد
الذي قال ان زلزال تركيا ينذر بخطر
التشينامي في المحافظات الساحليه لافتا
الى ان انقره اخطرت اربع عشره دوله بذلك
من بينها مصر الا ان الرئيس المعهد القومي
للبحوث الفلكيه في مصر جاد القاضي نفى
احتماليه حدوث امواج تسنامي خاصه ان
الزلزال لم يكن مصدره البحر
من القامش لينضم الى ينضم اليه الان عبر
سكايب مراسل العربيه جمعه كاش جمعه اهلا
بك معنا ماذا لدينا في اخر التفاصيل وخاصه
بالنسبه لحصيله الضحايا
مرحبا ميسون عداد الموت كان يرتفع بشكل
سريع اليوم في بدايه النهار كنا نتحدث عن
حوالي 1160 العدد الان تضع بحوالي الالف
عن 2160 قتيل في جميع المناطق السوريه
المتضرره والمدن الاساسيه الاسيه مع حلب
وادلب اللاذقيه وطرطوس حيث تستمر يعني
اعمال انتشال الجثث والبحث عن الاحياء في
جميع المواقع المنكوبه الانظار كانت
التوجه بشكل كبير الى مدينه جنديرس
الكرديه التي شهدت تحطم حوالي 84 مبنى
يعني الوصول الى حوالي 15 مبنى حتى هذه
اللحظه بينما لا يزال يعني العدد الاكبر
من المباني دون اي وصول من فراق الانقاذ
يعني ان هناك مئات من السوريين تحت انقاذ
هذه المنازل حتى الان المشهد نفسه كان
يتكرر وايضا في سرمدا ايضا هناك داخل
مدينه اللاذقيه لم يعني تتمكن الفرق
الانقاذ او وزاره الداخليه او حتى
من الوصول اليها وانتشار للجثث او الناجين
من تحتها
اين يعني يقطنون الان بالنسبه للجرحى ايضا
هل اوضاعهم ما زالت حرجه جدا مثلا لدينا
معلومات حول ذلك
الميسون يعني خلال الساعات النقل الاربعين
الماضيه تمكن يعني رجال فرق الانقاذ سوى
في مناطق المعارضه او النظام من انقاذ 450
شخص
تحديدا يعني في مدن يعني حلب العدد الاكبر
في مدن حلب
واللاذقيه هؤلاء
المصابين كان يتم نقلهم الى المشافي
الرئيسيه وايضا الى العيادات المتنقله
والنقاط الطبيه
داخل
المعارضه في شمال الغربي فاطمه وسوداء
واساويه لان الطاقم الطبي يعني استنفذ كل
طاقته ايضا تم استلفاز عدد يعني الكميه
الاكبر من الادويه والمعدات اللازمه
للعمليات الجراحيه
فعلا يعني
المصابين كانوا يعني ينامون او يستخدمون
الكريدورات او الممرات في المشافي كان
يتشاركون الاسره غرف العنايه او الغرف
الجراحه كان الاطباء يجرون عمليات جماعيه
يعني جريحين او اثنين او ثلاثه يتم يعني
اجراء العمليات المعقده حتى انهم في ان
واحده لانقاذ ما يمكن انقاذه ورغم ذلك
يعني خلال النهار عن احصائيه تفيد بان 84
شخص فارقه الحياه
بالنسبه لمراكز الايواء الجمعه اين تتركز
يعني
يعني مراكز الايواء تم يعني وضعها على
عجاله فبالتالي يعني السلطات المعنيه
استخدموا المرافق الموجوده
كالملاعب المغلقه وصالات الاعراس والنوادي
الرياضيه
يعني بعض المباني الحكوميه المباني
الحكوميه لكن الاعداد الكبيره من الناس
يعني اتجهت نحو الارياف وتشارك مع سكانها
المنازل ليله امس في جميع المناطق كان عدد
كبير من السكان مع العوائل يعني في
السيارات في مناطق مفتوحه بعيده عن
العمارات السكنيه ناموا في السيارات جزء
كبير ينام في في العراء دون وجود اي ماوى
من اشكال المعاونه التي
شكرا لك من القامش لمراسل العربيه يا
جماعه كاش على كل هذه التفاصيل من اسطنبول
ينضم الي مفرد العربيه غسان ابو لوز غسان
اهلا بك معنا ما هي ابرز التحديثات
للمعلومات ان كان لحصيله الضحايا الناجين
وضعهم على لسان المسؤولين الاتراك
بالنسبه لاعداد الضحايا ترتفع في كل ساعه
وتتغير واعداد الاصابات اخر الاحصائيات
يعني تجاوزت الاربع الاف وخمسمئه قتيل
ونحو 27 الف وهذا الرقم متغير وليس ثابت
ما دامت عمليات الانقاذ ما زالت مستمره
وما دام هناك عانقين تحت الانقاذ والركام
وتحاول السلطات ان يعني تسارع لانقاذ
هؤلاء في ظل ظروف جويه سيئه جدا ودرجات
حراره
متدنيه يعني بعض الكثير من الموجودين
والعالقين تحت الانقاذ الاهل
الثاني في
هذه الظروف وهذه الاجواء وهذه الحاله
وبالتالي الوضع صعب جدا
السلطات تواصل العمليات عمليات الانقاذ
بمشاركه كبيره من جميع مؤسسات الدوله سواء
كان من الجيش او المؤسسات الاخرى هناك
يعني تجهيز لخيام طوارئ
للتعامل مع حالات
المدنيين المنكوبين الذين فقدوا منازلهم
تم الاعلان عن تجهيز اكثر من 54 الف خيمه
سيتم ارسالها الى المناطق المنكوبه وايضا
هناك
الالاف من العاملين في القطاع الصحي
ارسلوا الى هناك
نحو 2500 الطبيب ايضا تم ارسالهم الى تلك
المناطق وايضا ذكر وزير الدفاع التركي بان
هناك
200 مستشفى ميداني
تم انشائها في تلك المناطق وهذا يشير الى
حجم الكارثه التي ضربت المناطق الجنوبيه
في تركيا
اي حد يعوق وصول المساعدات
ربما هو من ابرز يعني
الاسباب التي تعوق
دون وصول مساعدات بشكل سريع هي الطرق
المتضرره خصوصا في الولايات الجنوبيه التي
تعرضت للزلزال لكن يتم التعامل مع هذه
الطرق السلطات تحاول يعني ترميم والتعامل
مع الطرق التي يمكن التعامل معها وتطلب من
المدنيين بعدم يعني سلوك هذه
الطرقات حتى لا يكون هناك
ازمات مروريه والافتاح المجال امام فرق
الانقاذ والاغاثه والمساعده للوصول الى
هناك لكن هناك نبات شعبيه وهناك تضامن
شعبي واسع داخل تركيا في الولايات الاخرى
مع
الضحايا ومع المنكوبين يعني نحن في طريقنا
الى المناطق الجنوبيه خرجنا من من اسطنبول
منذ نحو 6 ساعات
يعني لا نستطيع السير سوى على مهل بسبب
الاحوال الجويه السيئه لا نستطيع ان يعني
نسير بسرعات الطبيعيه يعني سرعات متدنيه
على الطريق نلاحظ اليات محموله على شاحنات
تتجه الى تلك المناطق نلاحظ ان هناك
مواطنين
يحملون مساعدات اغاثيه ايضا
مركباتهم الخاصه وتاجهون الى هناك
وبالتالي هناك ايضا الالاف من الشبان
والشابات قدموا
لسلطات يعني
تطوعهم للمساعده في
في عمليات الانقاذ والاغاثه هناك اكثر من
60 الف عامل
مشارك في هذه العمليات عمليات الاجازات
وكما تعلمين ان هناك فرق اغاثه ترسل من
دول اخرى وتصل صحيح
اراضي التركيه يعني حسب المعلومات الرسميه
هاتاي مثلا هي الاكثر تضررا تليها كهرمان
مرعش وهذا يامان وغازي عنتاب والاقل تضررا
هي اضنه وديار بكر وشانلي اورفا وملايطه
وعثمانيه وكيليس هي اقل تضررا في تلك
المناطق لكن الان التحدي الاكبر امام
السلطات هي
الساعات المقبله في التعامل مع الظروف
التي يواجهون الطقس القارس ايضا اشكرك من
اسطنبول
صحيح
بانها ساعات 48 حاسمه مقبله على كل حال
غسان نتمنى ان تكونوا حذرين يعني خاصه على
الطرقات في ظل تواجد الثلوج على الطرقات
اشكرك على كل هذه المعلومات كنت معي من
اسطنبول وفي طريقك الى المناطق الجنوبيه
المنكوبه غسان ابو لوز مفاجاه العربيه
وطبعا وزير الدفاع التركيه يامر بفتح
القواعد العسكريه في مناطق الزلزال لايواء
المدنيين اذا حسب وزير دفاع تركيا قال بان
هناك فتح للقواعد العسكريه في مناطق
الزلزال والمدنيين
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
كارثه حلت بسكان جنوب تركيا وشمال سوريا
غضب الطبيعه في ساعات فجر الاثنين نتج عنه
زلزال مدمر هز المناطق الحدوديه بين
دولتين مباني مدمره قتلى وجرح بالالاف ولا
صوت يعلو على صوت الصراخ والاستغاثه اما
اهالي الضحايا خصوصا السوريين منهم فقد
زاد الزلزال معاناتهم بعد ان اختبروا
الموت بكل انواع الاسلحه والاوبئه فرقوا
الانقاذ جهدت في البرد وتحت الامطار
الغزيره والثلوج احيانا مستخدمه ادوات
بسيطه لانقاذ عالقين بين الانقاض اما في
تركيا الهيئه العامه لاداره الكوارث اعلنت
عن ارتفاع عدد القتلى الى اكثر من 4500
قتيله وفي سوريا يتواصل السباق مع الوقت
والبرد لانتشال الناجين مع وصول اعداد
القتلى الى اكثر من 2000 شخص
الله يصبرني فيكم يا ربي دخيلك صبر
قل لا اله الا الله
ومشاهدينا الى جانب عوامل الطقس وقله
الموارد كارثه الزلزال في سوريا تتضاعف مع
دخولها اليوم الثاني خصوصا ان معبر باب
الهوى الحدودي لا يزال مغلقا امام جميع
المساعدات الانسانيه وهو الشريان الوحيد
الذي يغذي المحتاجين في المنطقه منذ سنوات
لكن مسؤولا اغاثيا اوضح ان معبر باب الهوى
مغلق بالكامل بسبب الاعطال في الطرف
التركي فيما افاد بانه يمكن ان تتم
العمليه من معبر باب السلامه في ريف حلب
ومبعابر الراعي والجرابلس لنقل المساعدات
من تركيا الى سوريا
ولمتابعه المساعدات التي تاتي من الدول
ينضم الي من باريس حسين قنيبر مراسل
العربيه من موسكو ايضا عبد الجواد الرشد
مراسل العربيه حسين ابدا معك اولا ما
الفرق بين المساعدات التي ترسل الى تركيا
والمساعدات التي ترسل الى سوريا من قبل
فرنسا
اهلا بك ميسون بدايه المساعدات التي ترسل
الى تركيا هي تلك التي ترسلها الحكومه
الفرنسيه اما عبر وزاره الخارجيه او عبر
وزاره الداخليه او بالتنسيق بين هاتين
الوزارتين وبالتنسيق ايضا مع مركز الدعم
والازمات التابع لوزاره الخارجيه اما
الدعم الذي يصل الى سوريا فهو يصل حصرا
عبر منظمات انسانيه فرنسيه او منظمات
فرنسيه عامله ضمن منظمات امميه ودوليه على
سبيل المثال صباح اليوم وصلت الى تركيا
طائره خاصه على متنها عشره عناصر من
المجموعه الفرنسيه
المتخصصه في النجده من الكوارث هذه
الطائره الخاصه كان على متنها كانت هناك
معدات لتحديد مواقع الضحايا وايضا مولدات
كهربائيه مهمه هذه المجموعه التي تضاف الى
المئه وتسعه وثلاثين عنصرا في فرق الاطفاء
والانقاذ التي كانت وصلت الى تركيا صباح
اليوم ايضا مهمه هذه المجموعه العمل على
استخراج وسحب عالقين تحت الانقاض مهمه هذه
المجموعه وهي من خارج الاطر الحكوميه
العمل على
المساعده خلال ثمانيه ايام ستتواصل مهمتها
ووجهتها تحديدا غازي عنتاب هناك تحالف
المنظمات الانسانيه الفرنسيه الذي له فرق
على الارض تعمل خصوصا في غازي عنتاب وفي
اضنه وديار بكر واديمان وكلس ومالاتيا
وايضا فيها تاي واعلن ان فرقتين فرنسيتين
وسلطه صباح اليوم الى تركيا على متن
الطائره الاولى التي وصلت عند العاشره من
صباح اليوم ثلاثه 73
هم اعضاء في فرق انقاذ واطفاء ثم وصل
الطائره ثانيه على متنها خمسه وتسعون
عنصرا من فرق انقاذ واطفاء الفرقه الاولى
توجهت الى هاتاي وهي احدى ابرز المدن
المنكوبه في جنوب حقيقيه كما تعمل منظمات
اخرى من بينها منظمه اطباء بلا حدود التي
ساعدت ثلاثا وعشرين مؤسسه صحيه في ادلب
وحلب في سوريا تحديدا ساعدتهم بالفرق
الطبيه والمعدات الطبيه ساعدت مستوصفات
ومستشفيات وعيادات ميسون اشكرك حسين على
كل هذه التفاصيل والمعلومات انتقل الان
الى زميلنا في موسكو عبد الجواد الرشد
مراسل العربيه عبد الجواد بالنسبه لروسيا
ما هي ابرز المساعدات التي تقدمها لمنكوبي
هذا الزلزال
مساء الخير ميسون لك ولحسين دور موسكو بما
يخص عمليه الانقاذ والبحث عن عائقنا يعني
خلال ما حدث في تركيا او في سوريا يعني
يظهر في جزئين الجزء الاول هو وصول فرق
مختصه تابعه لوزاره الطوارئ الروسيه عددها
يصل الى اكثر من 100 عنصر الى الاراضي
التركيه والى اكثر من 50 شخص مختص الى
سوريا طبعا هذه الفرق وصلت مع معدات حديثه
وفرق من الكلاب من مهمتها طبعا وهي مدربه
بشكل كبير حسب روايه موسكو في البحث عن عن
اشخاص عالقين يعني اسفل هذه البيوت او هذه
الابنيه المدمره طبعا هذه الفرق قامت
بانشاء مشافي مؤقته وقامت بايجاد نقاط
طبعا طبيه في سوريا ومن مهمتها ايضا
استقبال الاشخاص الذا للتبرع بالدم حسب
الروايه وحسب التقارير الوارده من هناك
الوضع الانساني هناك سيء لدرجه كبيره طبعا
هذه الفرق بدات يوم امس وهو الجزء الثاني
من دور موسكو طبعا ان كان دبلوماسيا على
مستوى العاملين في السفاره في الاراضي
التركيه وان كان في مركز المصالحه الروسي
في سوريا عدد الاشخاص الذين شاركوا
بعمليات الانقاذ يوم امس وفي ازاله الركام
وفي تامين المساعدات وتقديمها لبعض
المواطنين في محافظات ثلاث سوريا وهي
اللاذقيه وحلب وجبله يصل عدد هؤلاء
المنقذين الى 300 شخص بالاضافه الى اكثر
من 60 اليه ان كانت عسكريه وان كانت مدنيه
على العموم طبعا ميسون موسكو ما زالت
تتحدث عن ان القرار الاول والاخير بدخول
المساعدات الدوليه الى الاراضي السوريه هو
متعلق بدمشق وحدها وهي الوحيده
على اتخاذ مثل هذا القرار ما زالت فرق
التابعه لوزاره الطوارئ الروسيه تعمل في
تركيا وتعمل في سوريا والتقارير ترد يعني
على مدار الساعه نقطه اخيره ميسون لو
سمحتي بها طبعا حديث الزلازل وما حدثه من
هناك هو هو حديث الشارع اليوم في موسكو
وفي مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي الكثير من
الناس تدعو الى ايجاد نقاط يمكن من خلالها
التقدم بمساعدات واحضار يعني الاشياء
والمستلزمات والمساعدات التي يمكن ايصالها
الى الاراضي السوريه شكرا لك من موسكو عبد
الجواد الروش مراسل العربيه واعود ايضا
واشكر زميلنا حسين
زلزال تركيا قد يكونوا اسوا كارثه طبيعيه
حلت على المنطقه لكن ما هي الزلازل كيف
تقع اصلا في الاساس لمعرفه هذا الامر
علينا الوقوف عند مكونات كوكب الارض اولا
وفقا لموقع هيئه المسح الجيولوجي
الامريكيه تتكون الارض من اربع طبقات
رئيسيه اللب الداخلي اللب الخارجي الوشاح
والقشره القشره والجزء العلوي من الوشاح
تشكل طبقه رقيقه على سطح كوكبنا لكن هذه
الطبقه لا تتكون من قطعه واحده بل من عده
قطع مثل الغاز بل مثل الغاز الصور المجزئه
والتي تغطي سطح الارض وهذه القطعه تسمى
الصفائح التكتونيه وهي تتحرك باستمرار
وببطء الا ان هذه الصفائح قد تنزلق عبر
بعضها البعض فجاه وعند انزلاقها قد تتعطل
حركه الصفائح التكتونيه بسبب الاحتكاك بين
حوافها وحواف الصفائح المجاوره هذا التعطل
يؤدي الى تراكم كميات هائله من الطاقه
بين الصفائحات وعندما ينفك هذا التشابك
يتم اطلاق كميات هائله من هذه الطاقه من
القشره الارضيه على شكل موجات زلزاليه
ويطلق على الموقع الموجود اسفل سطح الارض
حيث يبدا الزلزال اسمه المركز السفلي
ويطلق على الموقع الموجود فوقه مباشره على
سطح الارض المركز السطحي للزلزال ويحدث ما
يقرب من 20 الف زلزال كل عام وهو ما يعادل
حوالي 55 زلزالا كل يوم وفقا لهيئه المسح
الجيولوجيه الامريكيه لكن لحسن الحظ فان
غالبيه هذه الزلازل تمر دون ان يلاحظها
احد تماما وهي اضعف من ان تتسبب في اي ضرر
العاهل السعودي الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز
ووليد العهد الامير محمد بن سلمان وجهها
مركز الملك سلمان للاغاثه والاعمال
الانسانيه بتسيير جسر جوي الى تركيا
وسوريا وتقديم مساعدات صحيه وايوائيه
وغذائيه لتخفيف اثار الزلازل كما وجه
الملك سلمان والامير محمد بن سلمان بتنظيم
حمله شعبيه عبر منصه ساهم لمساعده ضحايا
زلزال
تفاصيل اكثر عن هذا الجسر الجوي من الرياض
ينضم اليه مراسل العربيه عبد المحسن
الحربي عبد المحسن اهلا بك معنا ماذا
لدينا من تفاصيل حول هذا الجسر الجوي الذي
يقدمه مركز الملك سلمان
نعم ميسون بالفعل خلال اقل من 24 ساعه
سينطلق هذا الجسر الجوي محملا بالكثير من
المساعدات الايوائيه بشكل رئيسي بالاضافه
الى مساعدات صحيه وفريق طبي كامل سيكون
برفقه هذه هذا الجسر واول طلائع عادل جسر
ستنطلق بعد ساعات من الان ربما اقل من 24
ساعه الساعه الواحده من ظهر يوم الغد
ستنطلق ايضا حمله شعبيه كبيره ستقوم فيها
مركز الملك سلمان موجهه لكافه المواطنين
والمقيمين في السعوديه للقيام بعمل عمليه
تبرع كبيره حمله تبرع حمله تبرع كبيره
لمتضرري الزلزال في سوريا وتركيا على حد
سواء وكل هذه المساعده هذه الحمله حمله
ساهم يعني كيف كيف هل هي ستكون اموال ومن
ثم هذه الاموال يتم شراء مساعدات انسانيه
للمنكوبين ام ستكون عباره عن مساعد
انسانيه طبيه غذائيه يقدمها من يريد ان
يساهم في هذه الحمله
بالفعل ميسون هي هذه المساعدات والحمله
التي ستنطلق في منصه ساهم عند الساعه
الواحده من ظهر يوم الغد ستشمل كافه انواع
المساعدات نتحدثنا عن المساعدات
الاغاثيه المباشره او الغذائيه او الطبيه
او حتى التي تتعلق بالشتاء وايجاد الملابس
اللازمه في هذا البرد القارس فبالتالي كل
هذه الاموال التي سيتم ضخها في هذه المنصه
من قبل المواطنين والمقيمين في السعوديه
سيتم تحويلها الى هذه المنتجات بشكل كامل
بهذه الصيغه سيتم ايصالها الى داخل التركي
وكذلك السوري في اقرب فرصه ممكنه سيتم
وصول هذه المساعدات بدءا من الغد وستستمر
هذه العمليه لايام ايضا سيكون هنالك طلائع
الجسر الجوي الذي سيبدا يوم الغد سيكون
برفقتي فريق من المختصين سيكون في الداخل
التركي وكذلك في سوريا تحديدا شمال غربي
سوريا بالتنسيق مع تركيا سيتم الدخول
المركز الملك سلمان الى المناطق
المتضرره من
الكارثه ومن كارثه الزلزال في تركيا في
سوريا بالاضافه الى تركيا وتقييم الوضع
بشكل دوري وبالاضافه الى هذا الجسر
المستمر سيكون هنالك تحديثات مستمره في
الحاجه الطارئه والعاجله
والمستحدثه بشكل يومي
لاستجابه السريعه لكافه الاحتياجات
بالاضافه الى انه المركز من خلال تصريحات
مسؤوليه قال بانه سيساهم في عمليه اعاده
الاعمار اعاده بناء هذه
المئات من المنازل التي تهدمت والالاف
سواء كان في الداخل التركي والسوري عبر
خبرائه ومختصيه الذين سيتواجدون في كافه
المناطق المتضرره في سوريا وتركيا لتقييم
الوضع بشكل عاجل بالاضافه الى المساعدات
العاجله التي من المفترض ان تصل خلال اقل
من 24 ساعه سيكون هنالك ايضا مساعدات ما
بعد عمليات الانقاذ وعمليات المساعدات
العاجله في عمليات اعاده الاعمار واعاده
بناء هذه
البيوت المهدمه بالتنسيق طبعا مع الجانب
التركي وفي الداخل السوري في شمال غربي
سوريا بالتنسيق مع الجهات والمنظمات
الاغاثيه في تلك المناطق ميسون اشكرك كانت
محسن الحربي على كل هذه المعلومات
والتفاصيل كنت معي من الرياض ونحن
مشاهدينا نتابع هذه الصور حقيقه صور قاسيه
جدا
للحظه الزلزال في كهرمان مرعش طبعا في
تركيا
شاهدنا المباني تتساقط
ونتابع هذه الصور ما زلنا نتابعها